oh no no no we don't even know what's  down there  treachery that's what's down come on  where's your sense of adventure  see what I tell you whatever than that  has been safely hidden for 2,000 years  this isn't a tomb it's a prison  Nick  the hieroglyphs said she was named R  Manette chosen to be Egypt's next Queen  but her thirst for power led her down a  darker path one that had to be stopped  because of your actions  this ancient power  has returned  you are alive because you were chosen  Sharon bar what evil mr. Morrow the  ultimate evil  [Applause]  legend has it she's a being an  imaginable power now she's using him to  attain  [Applause]  she will not stop  until she has remade our world into her  own I know you were good now you gave me  the only parachute without hesitation I  thought there was another one you can't  run you can't escape she's got plans for  you  so mommy no Laura tasaku oh you